venezuelan colombian edward castrillon
was doing his job in bogota recently
when he was stopped by the police for a
routine check he was dumbfounded when he
was told his colombian id was fake and
was arrested for 36 hours
i was in shock because i was sure i had
done nothing wrong they still handcuffed
me and took me to the police station
edward was born in venezuela but having
a colombian mother he was able to get
citizenship when he migrated here in
2019
but now he says he's living in a limbo
fearing he could end up in jail again
every time he leaves the house
a right to my identity has been violated
yes i was born in venezuela but already
have a life here a credit history
everything now i live in fear feeling
that i am some sort of criminal
and edward is not alone 43 000
venezuelan colombian citizens have lost
their ids in the last few weeks
colombia's national registry says they
found irregularities in their
documentation as part of a purging of
the electoral census their ids were
cancelled and the majority were not
notified since then more than 200 have
been arrested and others have had severe
consequences
the director of the civil registry says
that while the difficulty many faced are
unfortunate they had no option given the
fact the records show some irregularity
it's the mechanism we have in our
country to integrate people effectively
into the rule of law that will give them
all the guarantees that correspond to
them as colombian citizens but the
adjustment to the law is inevitably
applicable
but some suspect darker motives they say
the so-called irregularities could be an
excuse used by the government to reduce
the participation in upcoming
presidential elections of citizens
linked to socialist venezuelan
others claim it's the government's
heavy-handed response to allegations of
fake ids circulating in the country
whatever the reason it's having an
impact
who runs a human rights foundation that
assists venezuelan migrants has gathered
almost 5 000 wrongful cases
these people is colombian we are
colombian and every administrative
decision that you take affects the life
of these people today we have people
that have cancer and are not receiving
their treatment because these situations
leaving many to face the real life
consequences of bureaucratic decisions
beyond their control
alessandra ampietti al jazeera bogota